the republic a book that is considered
plato's magnus opus it is an attempt by
plato to define the ideal state and what
an attempt that was in 10 magnificent
chapters the philosopher manages to
immerse ourselves in dialogues
illuminating cognitive brilliance and in
philosophical concepts of the greatest
importance all of plato's books have
more or less the same format socrates is
the main hero so to speak and he has
dialogues with different athenians since
plato and socrates both lived in athens
and teached philosophy there the main
theme of the book is that of justice
with plato's background and experience
living in athens during the time of the
30 tyrants after the peloponnesian war
many people supposed that his experience
triggered the inception of the republic
whatever the case plato created a
philosophical work of extraordinary
significance that manages to inspire
western thought till this very day
why do people demand justice
why is justice at the epicenter of our
experience
is it because we fear social punishment
or is it something more visceral that
emerges from our desire to cooperate and
co-exist according to plato justice is
worthwhile in and of itself he begins to
support this thesis in a very
interesting way he introduces us to
thrassi mahouse a sophist a teacher for
hire for the wealthy sons of athens
sophists believe in subjective morality
or moral relativism as we call it today
they don't set them actions as right or
wrong but rather as advantageous or
disadvantageous for the people
performing them
tracima who's during a discussion with
socrates asserts that justice is nothing
else than the interest of the stronger
by that he means that the government is
concerned with justice and that people
should just follow the rules of the
government and sokratis refutes his
argument in a quite lengthy but in my
opinion genius way by explaining him how
governments can make errors then tracy
mahouse posits that injustice is better
than justice because the strong realize
how to take advantage of erroneous
systems to promote their interests
socrates clearly disagrees with that and
again refutes the argument in a lengthy
but genius way he proposes to look for
justice in the city first and then to
proceed by analogy to find justice
inside the individual plato from this
deep discussion on justice tries to
extrapolate what the ideal republic can
look like political justice is
predicated upon harmony on the way
society is structured an ideal state
consists of three main classes of people
rulers warriors and craftsmen the rulers
are philosophers who can reason and
think deeply and provide a good ruling
system for the city the warriors guard
the city from internal and external
threats the craftsmen are mainly
producers and provide the city with the
necessary products and services required
to run properly the reason plato decides
to use these three categories is because
he believes that people have three
fundamental behavioral tendencies
appetite spirit and reason and that in
every person one of the three tends to
prevail the ones who gravitate towards
appetite should become craftsmen
the ones in whom the spirit prevails
should become warriors and the ones who
hold the reason as the ultimate virtue
in life should become rulers after
rigorous selection and long periods of
training a society is just when
relations between these three classes
are balanced sokratis doesn't really
explain how the classification will
ensue but he suggests that all the
citizens should be told a noble lie
called the myth of the metals so as to
promote allegiance to the state and
enforce its three-tiered social order
according to this myth of metals every
citizen is born out of the earth of the
state and every other citizen is his
brother or sister yet god has created
them differently mixing different metals
into their soul
gold for the rulers silver for the
warriors and brass or iron for the
craftsmen children are usually made of
the same metal as their parents but if
this is not the case the child must
either descend or ascend in the social
order
mentioned before a society is just when
relations between these three classes
are balanced this is a direct parallel
to the human soul plato believes that
individual justice expresses itself
through the inner balance of the soul
its individual soul is affected by three
separate parts the appetite part lasts
after money food
drink and sex the spirit part yearns for
honor the rational part desires truth
and knowledge in essence we all have a
craftsman a warrior and a philosopher
ruler inside us
in a just so the power dynamics between
these three parts are specific the
rational part rules the spirit part
enforces the rational parts convictions
and the appetite part needs to operate
according to the directions of the
former two
plato realizes that if the rational part
doesn't rule the whole constitution of
the individual can fall apart he also
believes that the just soul strives
wholly towards the truth the idea of
truth is emblematic of his work and it
becomes apparent in the allegory of the
cave the cave symbolizes this limited
world that keeps us trapped and the
shadows are the only things we perceive
as real because of the limitations
imposed upon us when the prisoner
escapes and gains access to the outer
world he encounters the sun which is the
absolute truth plato makes three
important points in the allegory with
regards to the truth one that it takes
time to get accustomed to the truth and
eventually re-engineer one's perception
in order to understand it and accept it
number two that once one sees the truth
and accepts it one can never go back to
their former state and number three that
the truth can be perceived as something
dangerous by some people because often
the truth hurts so much that people will
feel that it's not worth risking what
they have for something so precarious
the manifestation of the truth-seeking
individual is the philosopher king
that's why he writes until philosophers
are kings or the kings and princes of
this world have the spirit and power of
philosophy and political greatness and
wisdom meeting one cities will never
have rest from their evils no nor the
human race as i believe and then only
will this state have a possibility of
life and behold the light of day i'm not
sure if the republic really constitutes
an attempt from plato to create the
ideal state or if it is an allegory and
a critique towards different forms of
government i'm on the same page with
plato with regards to the idea that we
need more philosophers in politics but
i'm not sure i agree with the rest
philosophy allows the thinking human to
study the greatest problems of mankind
in depth politicians don't do that
they're just actors in a flawed and
mostly corrupt system but a few of them
have actually studied philosophy and the
ones that did mainly scratch the surface
the difficulties of political life are
inescapable and require honest and
responsible participation plato believes
in hierarchies and propaganda and that
is very dangerous he tries to create an
elitist society both intellectually and
hierarchically obviously with good
intentions but it risks the fact that
this regime can easily regress into
authoritarianism people that don't
belong in the higher classes will always
feel inferior and grow resent towards
the other classes resentment is a very
dangerous feeling democracy is certainly
flawed and prone to manipulation but it
just state cares about the well-being of
all citizens without discrimination
intellectual development should be the
bedrock of all citizens and should
encourage people to participate and feel
included especially when it comes to
small-scale experiments and governance
in any case the republic is a seminal
work filled with great thought
experiments orchestrated by a genius
format called socratic dialogue plato is
one of the pioneers of western thought
and he will always fill our minds and
souls with innumerable moments of
inspiration and awe
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon either now